ce que vous avez déjà un mytho pour
pécho de bois vous gilles verdez je suis
sur le crépuscule s'abat sur le 15e à
paris au début des années 90 et à cette
époque là comme tous les soirs je
draguais sur minitel 36 15
aline et la schola la web
le gars de façon je voulais dire lui
c'était sûr et certain c'est ce thé où
il terminait en touche pas à mon pote où
il était en quartier de sécurité où il
abat brasse électronique un truc que je
voulais c'était sûr et certain et ça se
passe très bien avec marie-laure on
discute beaucoup
et au bout d'un manteau minitel ah oui
oui j'adore être et au bout d'un moment
je vous dis il faudrait en bouteille pet
les dossiers techniques ou dire le 5 mai
au bout de plusieurs jours plusieurs
semaines de discussions elle me dit
faudrait qu'on se rencontre à merde moi
mon genre de mec elle me dit c'est bruce
willis où il avait dit quoi bruce willis
web voilà je dis ça tombe oui c'est
bruce tout court dit ça tombe bien on
compare souvent à lui non donc j'ai
hésité un peu avant de la rencontre un
jour elle me dit écoute soit on se rend
compte soit on arrête pas normal c'est
tu ressembles à bruce lee donc j'ai le
rendez-vous dans un café à odéon je m'en
souviens et là elle me dit j'aurais une
robe rouge et où je lave d'anne
roumanoff
je la vois arriver elle est magnifique
donc je la vois entré dans le café alors
dit je fais comme ça c'est moi et là
elle me vois je vois dans sa tête que ça
passe pas à l'époque j'avais les cheveux
longs un peu hippie préféré la belle
paris alors mon image ap
[Applaudissements]
c'est bon on imagine avec bercy avec les
semaines on arrive à quelque chose comme
une idée assez pas non plus voilà hélas
elle fonce vers moi dans le café n'a
fait que c'est moi et elle me dit d'un
coup comme ça par mais tu te fous de ma
gueule tu m'avais dit que tu ressemblais
à bruce willis et tu ressembles à
francis lalanne capitaux pour pécho bah
oui oui vous avez dit mais c'était ok
mais quand ma chérie j'avais 14 ans et
les familles toujours vous aviez un cdd
sur m6 c'est dd ça veut dire
chroniqueuse définitivement installé
d'accord merci alors il a 12 ans et à
l'époque j'avais honte de pas avoir
d'autre il maintenant je vais largement
habitués et j'avais aussi des cheveux
très frisés donc j'avais honte et
j'avais un rouquin que j'adorais qui
avait le crâne comme wall-e un très joli
craindront un crâne de plus étaient mes
fans de ce garçon de carottes et tout
est donc une copine la somalie mère mary
donc je fais croire que ce sont mes
vrais cheveux à moyen et une copine me
rapporte que deux suisses des espèces de
tout c'est bien avant les implants qui
s'avère avoir à 4,70 et me met des
espèces d'un plan gélatineux à mettre
dans le soutien des mois qu'on n'avait
jamais mis et le mec est avec moi dans
un bateau à aix les bains et déjà il est
comme il est maladroit non ils sont
français mais je me mets au moment où
vous êtes au niveau de la mémoire
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
la gélatine aux exactions des marques de
moulage et le mec il me dit j'ai
toujours détesté les mac au moulage
il plonge je me laisse tout seul manque
pas de la connaît avec les 5
complètement enfoncé aulaqui maintenant
les cheveux
les sages les débuts de monter c'est pas
des coups d'accords alors oui j'aime
bien comme ça plus rapide et plus
intéressant j'avais rencontré à coiffeur
coloriste permanentiste c'est très rare
d'avoir des projets vous sentiez fabio
salsa trois spécialités rejeter coiffeur
ou que coloriste permanentiste accord
agence amateurs étaient les trois ils
étaient les trois femmes et où je
rencontre dans une soirée sensible un
jeune garçon est sensible soit les
soirées à thème
c'est à dire passer les soirées il ya
beaucoup de gens avec alors oui nous a
dit qu'il avait déjà fait un mytho pour
choper quelqu'un à l'heure exacte c'est
quoi une souris sensible mais non mais
c'est cette fois c'est comme quand on
vient de sortir il pouvait pas laisser
des soirées cif cdd soirée gay ah oui
mais c'est pas sensibles à ça si on
appelle ça les gens sortiront les plus
sensibles que les autres un d'accord
mais alors c'est sûr si vous êtes plus
con c'est l'animateur lendemain ils ont
un accès smara et je rencontre une
rareté ce que c'est rare d'avoir les
trois professions les trois spécialités
à un coiffeur qui est coiffeur coloriste
permanentiste d'accord avec ce message
où sa chasse à jouer
en tout cas ça m'interpelle oui vous
allez on passe au bac et du coup là et
il me dit qu'il est fan de justin bieber
a on va en parler dans l'instant
exactement
donc moi qu'est ce que je fais bîmes le
lendemain de mon amant l'assistant
d'appeler le producteur de justin bieber
de dire les mots magiques de leurs mots
et paf d'avoir deux places pour aller
rentrée de son mari
justin pour aller voir un concert de
justin exactement ça passe à bercy il ya
trois ans à peu près et je lui ai dit en
plus de ça je connais justin donc à la
fin du concert pam
on va le voir ceux présents mais justin
bridou de celle ci voulait voir
satisfait pas alors oui donc vous allez
au coureur de dot it bieber je me suis
un petit peu avant c'est parce qu'à
l'époque je connaissais pas justin
d'accord que depuis on sent que non non
non depuis sa vie personnelle je connais
pas et donc j'y vais effectivement je
sais qu'on pourra pas le rencontrer tout
le concert il est comme un ouf non non
on va le voir à quelle heure en vrac y
aura là et quand le concert se termine
jeudi je suis désolé j'ai reçu un texto
producteurs de justin bieber qui me
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
saluent ces watts dieu mais est-ce que
vous êtes bon
qui dit il est contente
alors vous alors et là vous croyez au
pas ça m'a plu les fêtes ça va être non
vie entier par sa mère pleurer si sûr
que c'est vrai le gap laissé coi son
prénom de septembre on s'en fout lorsque
prénom est un peu grotesque m'a dit que
mes amis kevin je les sors pas non mais
c'est pas non pas gros alors je m'excuse
mais c'est une femme ou le ghana est un
peu ton sur ton que vous dites et du
coup ça faisait un peu cliché mais t'as
pas peur pour tes audience non leur plat
et tout ça donc il
il a une épaule un peu un peu à la fois
robuste et sensible ga probant vous
n'étiez pas là si j'ai dit si tu veux on
va à la maison et on écoute de justin
bieber non bah ouais et le coin les
marchés en fait ce soir et c'est du rêve
au cauchemar
il est venu à la maison et le reste je
vous laisse se rêvait pas écouté j'ai
envie de vous dire que lui faites vous
plaisir
c'est pas sûr super bien il y avait pas
sûr alors je pense au fémina suis pas
allé après voudra vraiment très bien
c'est vrai vous allez rencontrer
audiblement aux dîmes allemand dans une
très court alors il dit non écoute
jamais mariés merci oui alors oui alors
j'étais encore ce voyage était encore en
boîte de nuit il y avait de très jolies
jeunes filles avec quatre jeunes filles
et je voulais absolument me rapprocher
d'elle jeudi à écouter où se trouve que
j'ai un bateau dans le port magnifique
tué mon père il fait 45 m une fois bien
jean pierre castaldi
ça commençait mal mais le connais de
soirée pour lui dire vous aviez fort
boyard et donc giba sortons la boîte de
nuit partons sur le bateau de mon père
est évidemment mon père n'a pas de
bateau de 45 mètres il avait vu d'ici
[Applaudissements]
un tout petit bateau de sept mètres de
long c'est vraiment tous les bateaux je
pars sur le port je prends un ponton que
je pense être bonne celui de mon père
est en fait c'est le contour des énormes
bateaux la plus on avance plus les
bateaux sont longs et là les filles se
rapproche de moi et honnêtement on
avance et là se rapproche et au keops
had me fait un énorme pas l'eau n'en
sent qu'on a des arrivées dans le truc
énorme qui te donne un bon bateau manque
de bajil pardon c'est pas le bon ce
fameux bonbons c'est à côté
on repart avec des 4,9 je prends le
ponton et dale voit que c'est que des
zodiac et là je dis et j'avance et je me
retourne les fils étaient barrées
[Musique]